je vais commencer par vous raconter une
petite histoire cette soirée commence en
2015 quand en sortant des clubs d'un
lien avec mon diplôme prêche points en
poche je rentre souvent du travail
je rentre le monde du travail et je
décide d'aller faire beaucoup de
personnes du consulting du consulting
dans un cabinet de conseil apparaît
premier job très bon salaire bref
j'avais en fait tout ce qu'on peut
espérer après avoir fait une école
d'ingénieurs tout ce que en fait on nous
promet après avoir fait unique en danger
j'étais comme on peut dire et peut-être
que vous avez déjà senti aussi ce
sentiment sur une autoroute
tout est facile tout est simple vous
posez n'a pas de questions c'est tout
droit on voit plus les sorties on est
bien fait on est juste bien ce sentiment
il dure qu'un temps tout cas pour moi il
a duré un an et demi ou d'un an et demi
j'ai senti que j'étais plus réellement
content de ce que je faisais je me
levais tous les matins c'était dur c'est
réellement durs je perdais un peu de
sens au travail
j'avais l'impression réellement d'être
goutte d'eau dans un océan d'être un
engrenage réellement une machine qui en
fait avait même pas besoin de moi qui
continue à tourner sans moi et là je me
suis dit ok je vais un peu ralentir sur
les autoroutes
je me demandais mais est ce qu'il n'ya
pas des sorties finalement est-ce que la
route elle est toute droite jusqu'à 50
ans jusqu'à la crise
la quarantaine de la cinquantaine je
suis j'ai un peu ralenti et je me suis
rendu compte que les autorités étaient
boutiques et énormément de sauver sa
luge se poser la question qu'est ce
qu'on aurait aimé en faire qu'est-ce
qu'on veut ré affaire me suis posé cette
question là et en fait je me suis
rappelé trois shows me première chose
c'est que j'adorais entreprend j'ai
toujours dans ma vie d'étudiant ou même
avant entreprises ont des projets j'ai
toujours été libre de faire mes propres
choix de prendre les pros décision
deuxième chose en mes études j'ai fait à
grenoble
j'étais très proche de la nature je
pense que j'ai passé plus de temps à 6
le siège des télés stick dans mes
enfants et troisième chose ça remonte
à ma petite enfance quand j'étais plus
jeune à nantes chez la mère l'avait
installé des ruches
là je me suis demandé au début quand il
a installé sa jeudi mais maman enfin
pourquoi tu fais ça
les allemands enfin j'avais peur je me
disais mais on va pouvoir aller dans le
jardin c'est horrible des ruches des
abeilles ça va piquer la m a expliqué
tout simplement et à force de la voir
faire je me suis rendu compte que
finalement la pisciculture que c'était
quelque chose d'incroyable on avait
besoin d'aller y entre l'environnement
pour la biodiversité
aujourd'hui la bei est en voie de
disparition c'est une espèce qui va
bientôt disparaître si on fait rien et
pourtant elle est responsable d'un tiers
de toute la nourriture qu'on mangeait la
salle de la pollinisation
alors avec ces trois certitudes en poche
je me suis dit que j'allais prendre une
sortie à cette autoroute
j'ai pris la sortie de l'entrepreneuriat
j'ai fondé cofondé en 2016 une
association qui s'appelle apiculteurs
qui propose de préserver la biodiversité
l'apiculture dans nos villes alors vous
allez me dire pas pourquoi les villes en
fait finalement pas ce que tu lui as dit
tout alors que tu adores et ballades et
mentale en fait bizarrement parce que la
ville offre un refuge de biodiversité
pour l'année pourquoi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de pesticides en ville
voire même pas du tout comme en campagne
aujourd'hui et même plus une variété de
fleurs qui fleurait à différents moments
de l'année permet à la veille de se
nourrir toutes vos longues années on
s'est dit ok bah lançons cette
association marié en fait dans mon
entourage ya beaucoup de gens qui se
sont demandé également mais pourquoi en
fait fait ça est ce que tu vas être
heureux est ce que c'était un peu
dangereux finalement quitté mon emploi
ton cd ita sécurité pour se lancer dans
l'entreprenariat et en plus faire
l'agriculture c'est toi paris c'est à
dire que je suis passé un costume
cravate un costume d'apiculteurs je fais
me passer de salles de réunion éclairée
par des néons à des toits de paris
éclairée par le soleil tout simplement
en fait ce que j'arrivais pas à le
redire à cette époque là et qu'ils ont
compris maintenant c'est que pour moi
c'est pas le salaire est lui même la
reconnaissance qu'ils venaient emporter
réellement c'était réellement le sens
que je pouvais donner l'impact que je
pouvais avoir à travers
l aujourd'hui avec apiculteurs mais
douze bénévoles aussi une association
douze bénévoles qui compteront vraiment
pas notre temps pour ramener un peu de
diversité dans la vie on organise des
ateliers de sensibilisation découverte
de l'apiculture pour permettre à tous
les parisiens aujourd'hui de francs
compte de ce que c'est le métier
d'apiculteur
on se rend compte que à leur niveau ils
peuvent vous y protéger les béliers
c'est possible on a aussi ouvert une
école de formation
et ça c'est quelque chose de réellement
incroyable parce que en fait chaque
année on va former des personnes à
l'apiculture des personnes qui en fait
envie de se reconvertir les personnes
qui ont envie de vivre leur passion et
je crois qu'il ya réellement rien plus
beau que de permettre à des gens de
vivre de leur passion et cette année
aussi avec la on se lance un
nouveau défi
on veut fleurir tous les balcons des
parisiens alors parce que lancer des
ruchers bien mais effectivement mettre
des fleurs c'est encore mieux
on veut comme on dit dans l'assaut
mettre des fleurs à tout les coins de
rue alors voilà où on en est aujourd'hui
et ça fait effectivement que commencer
j'ai pas fait ça que comme au choix pour
moi il y avait plusieurs choses qui
avaient de l'importance effectivement
vous avez et rendu compte
l'environnement
mais il y avait aussi permettre aux gens
de vivre de leur passion c'est avoir un
impact pour ça qu en 2007 j'ai rejoint
une autre association chef étiquette
orange il permet à chacun d'avoir un
impact à travers son travail
moi mon rôle c'est d'accompagner chaque
année 50 entrepreneurs on appelle les
entrepreneurs du changement qui mettent
leur énergie leur temps leur travail au
service de la réduction des enjeux de
société aujourd'hui ce sont
des gens comme et marin qui permet aux
agriculteurs conventionnels de basculer
vers un mode d'agriculture un peu plus
écologique de l'agroécologie avec des
outils des financements et la formation
ce sont des gens aussi comme philippe
qu'on accompagne qui s'attaque à
l'artisanat d'art qui veut faire que
cette ce métier ne périclite pas avec le
temps c'est des gens aussi comme azad
qu'on aide qui permet aux jeunes de
banlieue il suffit quartiers défavorisés
d'entreprendre d'avoir les mêmes chances
de tous alors derrière toutes ces belles
histoires que je vous raconte c'est
derrière ces dessins le mien et ceux des
entrepreneurs des changements en fait il
ya une réalité qui est beaucoup plus dur
il ya une réalité qui est que on a des
doutes sur ces questions tous les jours
on se remet aussi en question et on se
dit mais ce que c'est tellement ça qui a
de l'importance pour nous est ce que
c'est vraiment ça qui a des valeurs
pourquoi je le fais j'étais pas mieux
dans mon entreprise avec mon cdi est ce
que j'avais pas vraiment de problème
finalement effectivement quand on
poserait un salaire de consultant à
celui d'un entrepreneur apiculteur à
paris ben on est un peu obligé de revoir
son niveau de vie on peut plus faire
tout ce qu'on faisait avant on peut plus
sortir tout en peux plus aller dans les
restaurants tout fait ce soir et c'est
plus possible tout simplement parce
qu'on a moins d'argent et donc du coup
on redéfinit un petit peu ce qui arrive
quand serons nous c'est quoi nos
priorités qu'est ce qui a de
l'importance
qu'est ce qu'il ya de la valeur
réellement et en faisant ça on
effectivement on a une vie un peu plus
simple mais on se rend compte qu'on est
beaucoup plus heureux parce que chaque
chose qu'on fait ou qu'on a réellement
du sens et la valeur pour nous
aujourd'hui ce que ce que je suis venu
vous dire en fait c'est vraiment ça
c'est que pour moi être audacieux c'est
pas du tout monté la dernière start-up
impact à monter
la dernière start up qui va décoller la
licorne comme dit non c'est pas du tout
ça pour moi c'est arrivé à redéfinir ce
qui pour vous l'importance et vivre au
quotidien changer sa façon de vivre au
quotidien pour être plus en accord avec
ça c'est ça pour moi kyoto qui est être
là dessus alors en fait on n'est pas
obligé de se mettre dans des situations
économiquement difficile pour se poser
cette question là on peut tout
simplement ce rendez vous un peu avec
soi-même à exposer cette question mais
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'important sur glace
a fait plein de choses ça peut être la
famille ça peut être les amis le sport
l'alimentation l'environnement plein de
choses il ya plein de personnes
aujourd'hui qui montrent l'exemple
qu'ils changent leur façon pied par
exemple si pour vous c'est
l'environnement tient bel environnement
vous pouvez arrêter d'acheter vos
comptes ce supermarché vous pouvez
consommer local à consommer de saison
vous pouvez par exemple aussi entamé une
démarche zéro déchet vous pouvez acheter
les épiceries dans les épiceries en bacs
tout mettre dans des bocaux vous pouvez
aussi par exemple arrêter d'acheter des
vêtements neufs
elle est dans les friperies vous pouvez
aussi acheter par exemple que les
vêtements qui vous sont essentiels
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous
connaissez mais il ya un projet qui est
assez intéressant là dessus sur le
textile qui aujourd'hui les industries
les plus polluantes au monde qui
s'appelle le projet 3,33 et ce projet
gelé un piqué mon quotidien j'ai changé
mon quotidien en suivant ce concept là
il y est très simple il s'agit
d'utiliser que 33 vêtements différents
et d'en changer que quelques-uns tous
les trous noirs au fil des saisons et en
fait ce qui s'est passé qui as est
extraordinaire c'est que je me suis
rendu compte que en fait utilisé que 33
vêtements déjà mes gars d'avoir
rencontré plus de 70 et j'utilisais 33
vêtements
ce qui m'a permis de redonner plus les
vêtements utilisés par des personnes qui
en avait sûrement beaucoup plus faisant
croire
si pour vous c'est pas l'environnement
mais c'est par exemple la famille ou les
amis vous dit
j'adorerais passer plus de temps avec
eux mais je pars je travaille trop bas
peut-être une solution et je pense
qu'elle a le mérite de se la poser c'est
est ce que vous avez envie de travailler
autant est ce que par exemple vous
pouvez pas ne travailler que
quatre jours sur cinq est ce dire que
sur le joug qui reste vous passer plus
de temps avec ma famille vos amis
on va faire votre loisir leur
effectivement vous avez galimant
d'argent c'est évident ce travail aimant
mais est ce que le temps vous allez
dégagez n'a pas plus de valeur que
l'argent que vous auriez pu aligner
aujourd'hui on a tendance à croire que
l'argent est ce qu'il y avait plus de
valeur et c'est la société qui nous dire
depuis qu'on est tout petit a lady bombe
à l'argent ça vous permet d acheter
acheter ça vous permet pas posséder des
biens etc et posséder c'est la réussite
donc il faut garder de l'argent il faut
pour être heureux aujourd'hui il faut
gagner de l'argent or cela c'est
complètement faux c'est complètement
faux il ya énormément de l'initiative de
personnes qui montre qu'aujourd'hui on
peut vivre différemment et une économie
différends qui existent et des gens qui
changent et leur quotidien et des gens
qui décident de mettre leur travail au
service un enjeu de société qui a envie
de résoudre cet enjeu de société
ce que je venu ce que je suis venu vous
dire aujourd'hui c'est que si on veut
changer notre société si on veut
réellement aller dans le bon sens tous
ensemble en fait ça se commence surtout
parlant ça commence surtout par avoir
l'audace avoir le courage de dire que
notre quotidien a besoin d'être changés
de redéfinir ce qui pour nous a de la
valeur a de l'importance et l'appliquer
au quotidien et c'est possible